jetzt kommt natürlich dass das für mich
persönlich ganz große aufreger thema
vielleicht
der grösste
menschengemachte skandal
der mich zweifeln lässt an der
zukunftsfähigkeit
unserer bewährten westlichen
demokratischen freiheitlichen
marktwirtschaftlichen gesellschaft denn
wir sind im begriff diese gesellschaft
auf der grundlage freiheit
eigenverantwortung
marktwirtschaft ganz gezielt zu
verschrotten zu opfern auf der
schlagbaum
rot-grüner illusion und ich muss das in
diese drastische darstellen bei mir in
den letzten tagen bewusst geworden ist
dass das was wir gemeinhin oberflächen
als klimapolitik bezeichnen dass diese
klimapolitik das für unsere welt viel
größere und konkrete risiko ist aus der
klima- und ich verfolge mit größter
sorge wie das klima wie die umwelt
missbraucht wird von politischen
demagogen und ideologen die unter
ausschaltung der diskussion die unter
stürmischem auto von kritischen stimmen
im begriff sind uns zu industrialisieren
liebe korrekte industrialisieren das
heißt zum beispiel wir steuern auf eine
situation zu ohne strom was man auch die
journalisten wie blindheit geschlagen
sie sagen uns ja wie können wir ohne
strom überleben in der schweiz lesen wir
schon kochtipps ohne strom wissen sie
was das heißt das heißt wir haben keine
zahlungsverkehr mehr wir haben keine
energie versorgung mehr zu hause wir
müssen uns von konserven ernähren ich
habe noch gar nicht von den
arbeitsplätzen gesprochen wir stehen
hier auf ein neues mittelalter als eine
art der grünen freizeitpark zu das geld
hinten und vorne nicht darauf man
spricht aufgrund von ich bin gleich
fertig ich weiß das wird jetzt langsam
in st
es ist unglaublich auf der grundlage von
computermodellen für die nächsten 100
jahre dabei können wir nicht noch das
wetter von übermorgen voraussagen werden
massive eingriffe in unsere
gesellschaftsordnung gemacht also der
klimawandel und das ganze zusammen zu
fassen ist viel weniger gefährlich der
klimawandel aber jetzt von menschen oder
sonstwas gemacht ist als die
klimapolitik und wir brauchen hier wie
der freiheitliche marktwirtschaftlich
gestellt die dagegenhalten um
sondershausen was ich gesagt habe wo sie
das studio vibriert und ich freue mich
wirklich darauf ja sowas von kontraste
größer ist natürlich völlig unrecht der
die klimakrise ist und bleibt die größte
herausforderung das größte risiko für
die spezies mensch aber was wir
natürlich schaffen müssen ist unsere
industrie zu dekarbonisierung und nicht
zu de industrialisieren und das wird
richtig aufwendig und das wird richtig
teuer ich rede hier von der
stahlindustrie von der zementindustrie
von der chemieindustrie und dafür
brauchen wir einen klaren politischen
rahmen und diesen politischen rahmen den
fordert die wirtschaft ja auch den
fordern großen dax-unternehmen den
fordern die stiftung zwei grad zum
beispiel also den brauchen wir aber was
mir wirklich fast noch wichtiger ist an
der stelle wir müssen endlich anfangen
diese transformation als chance zu sehen
als aufbruch deutschland hat die chance
sich neu zu erfinden sich an die spitze
zu setzen einer globalen transformation
die so fundamental ist wie keine
ökonomische transformation je zuvor also
wo sind die politiker die sagen das ist
unsere chance das in unsere klima
utopien das ist aber nicht nur verzicht
und das ist nicht nur teuer und
risikovermeidung sondern das ist unser
aufbruch und damit können uns neu
erfinden also ich bewundere hier diesen
jugendlichen enthusiasmus und ich kann
die usa geliefert herr doktor
verlässlich wünsche ihnen viel vergnügen
sie haben die stahlindustrie die
chemieindustrie die bauwirtschaft
angesprochen wissen sie was passieren
wird das kann ich ihnen jetzt hier
sorgen diese industrien werden aus
deutschland aus europa verschwinden die
amerikaner werden auch diese industrien
übernehmen die chinesen werden sie
übernehmen und wir werden uns hier
selber opfern auf dem altar unseren
illusionen während all diese großmächte
denen wir uns dann zwischendurch die
schuhe putzen und denen wir dann mit dem
erhobenen zeigefinger sagen was sie
alles zu tun und zu lassen haben die
werden dann einfach die industrien
übernehmen die wir hier einfach auf der
schlachtbank auf der grünen schlachtbank
verschrottet haben das ist meine
befürchtung und ich traue der politik
tschuldigung ich traue der politik die
kompetenz für einen solchen
planetarischen prozess schlicht nicht so
ich bin selber im nebenamt politiker und
ich zitiere napoleon unterschätze nie
den faktor inkompetenz in der politik
und damit meine ich mich sehr brauche
ich würde meine inkompetenz ihre
überhaupt nicht
unterschätzen in diesem zusammenhang
aber
politiker dieses urvertrauen also wir
schaffen dass herr dr lässt ich glaube
man müsste ihnen hier den nobelpreis ihr
optimismus verleihen diesen
aber das klingt ja dann auch ein
bisschen so als würden die menschen in
den anderen ländern in china und so
weiter nichts vom klimawandel mit
bekommen also ich meine was muss
eigentlich noch passieren dass wir
menschen irgendwann mal kapieren dass
wir uns jetzt mal bewegen müssen und das
werden auch die chinesen kopieren oder
alles klar moment moment kapieren die
chinesen vor allem ihre marktchancen
also im moment wenn wir wie co2 moment
ist es konkret so dass wir die co2
grenzwerte so hin absetzen dass man
stahl definitiv in deutschland auf lange
sicht nicht mehr produzieren kann aber
wird es weiter stahl geben ja aber er
wird dort nicht mehr in deutschland
gemacht sondern wird in china gemacht
also das ist das ist das ist absolut es
habe aber nicht lösung für uns ich
glaube ich habe längst aufgegeben dass
wir europa dass wir europa darauf die
im wettbewerb mit china überhaupt noch
eine chance haben de facto ließ nun ein
wir werden wir werden aus europa einfach
in diesem land machen wo dann die ganzen
reichen chinesen wieder jackman kommen
und unsere schönen und sich ihre häuser
kaufen die werden dann die werden dann
sind wir werden in diesen sie lernt
werden sowieso wie die amerikaner was
nach rothenburg ob der tauber fahren
wird ganz ganz europa mit einer art
ordnung ob der vorgang nein sage ich den
optimismus ist sage ich mal wo die
chance liegt der europäischen union von
europa wenn wir nämlich mal die welt
situation analysieren was passiert hier
richtig in china ist ein nostalgiker
macht namens schinken was wie schinken
er dementiert die chinesische
marktwirtschaft in dem er die
kommandowirtschaft nach oben blickt im
weißen haus sitzt ein von wilden
sozialisten ferngesteuerter teleprompter
namens joe biden und die amerikaner sind
auch dabei ihre box modell der
marktwirtschaft auf den opfern
darzulegen was muss die europäische
union tun was muss deutschland tun ihr
habt hier ein wirtschaftswunder
hingelegt ihr habt eine marktwirtschaft
aufgebaut ihr habt eine industrie wunder
geschafft wir müssen uns in europa auf
unsere freiheitlichen
marktwirtschaftlichen traditionen
besinnen und das heißt das wird die
umweltprobleme im privaten sektor durch
private innovation und nicht doch diese
storz große dach diese rot-grüne
planwirtschaft ohne plan
jetzt wo ich wohne
ich hier nur in einer sache recht es
wird nicht der staat sein der unsere
wirtschaft transformiert wird die
wirtschaft sein die unsere wirtschaft
transponiert ob er hilft mir jetzt gut
doch so als wenn die stahlindustrie dann
nach amerika oder nach china geht die
wahrheit ist doch im neuen
fünfjahresplan der chinesen da ist doch
klimaschutz längst verankert und die
werden sich noch strengere ziele geben
die wahrheit ist gekommen war ist du
hast in wahrheit ist doch dass die
amerikaner uns in vielen industrien weit
voraus sind in sachen klimaschutz das
ist wie bei der digitalisierung welches
unternehmen war es dann dass die
elektromobilität vorangetrieben hat
tesla tesla hat viele an automobilen ist
automobilhersteller vor sich hält trägt
ein unternehmen aus amerika ähnliches
wird meines erachtens auch im bereich
der nachhaltigkeit technologien
passieren wenn wir jetzt nicht aufpassen
und wenn wir diese chance und diese
chancen relativ nicht aufbauen aber das
ist ja was ist denn ihre lösungen an
sich man kann ja viel rum tümpeln und
sagen und klimawandel und den
industrialisierung und so weiter aber
was was sagt ihr denn dank oppelner
wandel egal wie rasen alles in die luft
da fängt schon an dass man diese hoch
differenzierten argumente die ich da
gebracht auch wenn die projekte wichtig
meine bescheidenen erfahrung
besteht darin dass ich sage unsere
freiheitlichen marktwirtschaftlichen
demokratischen gesellschaften haben sich
in der vergangenheit durch wo aufgrund
ihrer flexibilität und der
innovationskraft im privat den sektor
als
anpassungsfähiger erwiesen als staaten
die alles auf den start auf die zentrale
gelegt haben das ist meine kritik ich
bin nicht gegen umweltschutz ich bin
nicht gegen saubere luft aber ich sage
den weg den wir marschieren ist
schwierig hier eine tier habe ich den
aktionsplan der europäischen zentralbank
die jetzt den banken in europa
vorschreiben will ihm was sie noch
investieren dürfen an der spitze der
europäischen zentralbank sitzt eine
politikerin frau lagarde da sage ich
deutsche vergräbt oder sport es bringt
euren geldbeutel in sicherheit wir sind
auf einem strip auf einem
staatsgläubigkeit trieb und ich plädiere
für umweltschutz in einem
marktwirtschaftlichen
demokratischen gesellschaft in der sich
die politiker wieder viel mehr
zurücknehmen müssen aber wir sind jetzt
im trainingslager eines super starts
durch corona und ich kann sagen das geht
gleich weiter mit dieser grünen gucken
ganz strich etwas gutes an roche das ist
auch meine überzeugung dass die
wirtschaft der motor unserer
gesellschaft ist und die politik
eigentlich nur die rahmenbedingungen
setzen den letzten jahren gab es aber
leider was ich auch sehr bedauere einen
shift dass man eigentlich schon sieht
und viele der grünen empfinden das ja
auch so dass der staat die oberste
instanz der vernunft ist was man einmal
gesehen hat auch während der korona
pandemie der staat ist eine wahnsinnig
schlechter unternehmer zwei beispiel nur
impfstoff schnelltest machen traurig
sein denn trotz nur sagen deswegen
glaube ich schon dass du da
wichtige these die wirtschaft ist unser
motor und der staat muss ich eigentlich
mal wieder ein bisschen zurückhalten
damit die wirtschaft auch motor sein
kann aber ich glaube schon wenn der
staat immer mehr regel macht das
schüttelt auch kreativität die wir
brauchen damit unternehmen sich kreative
lösungen ausdenken kann gehen oder sogar
ein bisschen mit aber mit den
innovationen ist er schon auch so eine
sache der stadt gibt ja die
rahmenbedingungen aber die unternehmen
gehen auch immer genau so weit wie es
geht es kommt ja keiner auf die idee zu
sagen ich habe meine geile innovation
und stoße einfach von vornherein mal
weniger co2 aus ich war
immer dass wir weniger co2 ausstoß bei
autos brauchen oder was auch immer
stickoxid das ist 100 jahren gefühlt auf
der agenda und trotzdem gehen alle immer
genau bis zum ende der grundschule aber
da sie am liebsten hören lassen um einen
konzern aber was worin ist deutschland
weltmeister deutschland ist weltmeister
bei den hidden champions die
familienunternehmen dass es unser
rückgrat und es gibt ganz viele
familienunternehmer die längst co2
neutral wenn man auf linkedin ist und
denen folgt und man sehen was sie für
umwelt initiativen machen die heißen nur
nicht vw sondern die heißen dann kleinen
namen in kleinen städten mit irgendwie
300 mitarbeiter und geben richtig gas ja
aber diejenigen geredet ja nicht so dass
die jeden champions und die
familienunternehmen machen ja schon viel
auch in der autoindustrie übrigens nur
weil sich schon glaube ist wir müssen
schon aufpassen dass der staatlich
irgendwann die der höchste die höchste
instanz der vernunft ist weil ich dann
glaube ich auch dass wir ein problem
kriegen aber du hast die these angemacht
dir gehört auch eine schlusswort ja die
lebendigen runde interessante ist doch
dass die wirtschaft gar nicht so redet
wie dieser teil des tisches sondern die
wirtschaft fordert einen rahmen einen
rahmen für investitionen die jetzt
getätigt werden müssen und die wachstum
produzieren werden aber ganz wichtig
auch das hat mich heute morgen geärgert
dass ich klassik radio gehört habe in
diesem appell der wirtschaft diesen
umbau zu beschleunigen steckt natürlich
auch der ruf nach subventionen drehen
und das ist die nächste gefahr dass die
klimapolitik den ganzen privaten sektor
in eine staats abhängigkeit in eine
subventions abhängigkeit hinein bläst
den neuen spiegel da steht man müsse das
alles
jetzt schnelle taten sprechen lässt im
spiegel nun steht dreht man müsse die
umverteilung man müsse die ganze
verbrühung die sind konkurse trip müsse
man damit sozialer gestalten da
marschieren wir in eine wirklich
sozialistischen grünen öko marxismus
marschieren wir hinein ich bin für
ökologie aber ich bin gegen mexiko
[Musik]